so did you ever actually get to meet him
after you did this who John Cena oh no
of course not it's a whole yeah well
that's a bummer I mean I think he posted
did he post about it as well and when he
found out I don't know if he posted for
himself but his page he put he put the
picture of me on there he doesn't say
anything he doesn't caption he doesn't
tag me if nothing he's because you can't
see him you're gonna die
I love him a lot alright well it's a
first season he's not here where you
know a small budget but I'm doing you're
watching but wait see he's watching and
he's gonna love this moment and I want
you to perform this song will you Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this